all snakes are carnivores but certain
ones like this king cobra in southern
india have a freed election for other
snakes in this case a rat snake humans
often confuse the rat snake with the
Cobra and kill it but here's what's
different cobra big rat snake smaller
cobra capable of rearing up into scary
attack pose rat snake not Cobra venomous
rat snake has none cobra are ready to
munch rat snake soon to be lunch but not
without a fight we can't know what the
Cobra is thinking but it's got to be
annoying when you're trying to eat
something and that something is trying
to bite you back now the king cobra can
be cannibalistic but if another species
is handy they're preferable
king cobra venom kills the rat snake in
minutes in this amazing film footage we
see how one snake eats another ever see
kids attack a big plate of spaghetti
where they take one huge strand and suck
it into their mouths inch by inch by
inch to the horror of their parents
that's how the king cobra doesn't the
cobra can't chew its prey it swallows
the rat snake hole and then the strong
acids in its stomach go to work
rat snake good to the last delicious
scale